scp-2273 a mysterious euclid-class
humanoid entity known as major Alexi
belotrov is believed to be from an extra
Universal origin consisting of symbiotic
relationship between a non-anomalous
human
scp-2273-1 and an anomalous organism
scp-2273-2 the organism possesses a
chitinous carapace compound lensed eyes
and advanced musculature providing the
host with exceptional abilities such as
carrying up to 1 200 kilograms it also
has a proboscis for nutrient extraction
and an organic radio transceiver for
communication its exterior is heavily
scarred with markings that suggest a
military background as a major in a
Russian armored Infantry Division
discovered in Wisconsin in 1989 major
melatrov was wounded malnourished and
Delirious upon recovery now contained in
a specialized cell at site-17 it
undergoes weekly psychological
assessments to maintain mental health
and reveal further information about its
Origins